[موسيقى]
لا ينقطع بكاء هذا الطفل الصغير
لا يعرف من الشكوى سوى مناداه والدته
دخان دخان
اما الاخرون الذين دمر الزلزال بيوتهم
وشردهم الى العراق فيعرفون كيف يوصلون
شكواهم لكنهم لا يعرفون ان كان ثمه من
يستجيب لهم
بعضهم حدثونا واخرون لم يستطيعوا الكلام
رب العالمين
فحدثنا عن فظاعه ما مر به ومعايشه
كنت نايم صار الزلزال بالليل وقع علي
الحياه
وايدي ورجله انكسره وقاعده هون بالبرد
بدي احكي ما بعرف نايمين على
الارض سبعه ايام اليوم صار لنا على الارض
سبعه ايام انا واياد مرضى عندي الاولاد
مرضانين من البرد
يعني الوضع اسوا من هيك يمكن مستحيل
[موسيقى]
يعني شايفين يعني عيونكم ذبحنا البرد
والله العظيم مثل البرد والجوع ومرضانه
وانا مره يعني
احد عشر الف عائله شردها الزلزال شمال
غربه سوريا
بعضها حظيه بخيمه او مكان في مركز ايواء
لكن كثيرين منهم باتوا في العراق
هنا ينامون وياكلون ان وصلهم شيء من الخبز
والطعام
مر اكثر من اسبوع على الزلزال لكن ارتجاف
اجسادهم كل ليله لا يقل الما عن اليوم
الذي دمرت فيه بيوتهم
قد لا تكون المعاناه جديده على حياتهم
لكنها من اكبر الماسي التي حلت بهم
تحت الصفر لا ماوى ولا دفء سوى هذه النار
ضين ساعات مع هذه العائلات النازحه التي
شردها الزلزال انهم هنا منذ سبعه ايام في
العراء والمعاناه ينتظرون الغوص ويسالون
هل من مجيب
عمرو حلبي الجزيره من محيط جنديرس ريفحلب